it's time to revisit some old friends
[Applause]
[Music]
so Doctor Who big finished time and this
turned into a slightly bigger project
than I originally intended it to be cuz
I didn't do my research before giving
options to my patrons to decide which
stories to vote on so long story made
short I had purchased a number of
actually I've done basically all of the
second season of the Fourth Doctor
adventures from Big Finish with Tom
Baker back as the doctor and that this
season also features Mary Tam returning
as a Romana 1 now I had just picked a
story actually I think maybe two stories
and plus one other thing for therefore
my patrons to vote on and the one that
they picked was the Dalek contract now
because I'm dumb or you know also
allergic to research I did not realize
that I had basically put up and then
they had selected the first half of a
more-or-less two-part story that's also
continuation from a previous basically
two-part story and so I listened to it I
finish I'm like I know I'm coming into
the middle of something and I was right
so what I'm actually gonna review now is
basically four stories officially I
consider it to be two because two out of
these four don't aren't complete you
know without the one that immediately
follows or immediately precedes it and
and there is a sort of a thematic
through line for these four so I'm
covering a little more than half of the
Fourth Doctor adventures season two so
this means that the stories that I'm
covering are the sands of life the war
with the land or lon Oh Karen
they pronounced it now was live war
would the lawn again should I check that
research and then that was followed up
by the Dalek contract the one that I
actually oh he tried to do as his own
thing and didn't work and then finally
the final phase so let's start talking
with the characters because the
characters are the highlight they're
also the reason I came to this so
obviously Tom Baker back at the Fourth
Doctor he hasn't missed a step I won't
lie it took me a little bit of time to
get used to the just the fact that he
sounds older not that he sounds like
wizened or decrepit or anything but the
tone and quality of his voice has aged
it has changed I kind of went through
the same thing when I watched the the
animated Batman things that Return of
the King Crusaders that brought Adam
West back to voice Batman again you know
he's still got it absolutely but his
voice is not identical to what it used
to be so it takes a little while to sort
of get used to that also it's basically
the same case with Mary Tama the
unfortunately and I hadn't realized this
when I bought these but but again this I
did I did do research and check the
unfortunately late Mary Tam she actually
she passed away I had missed this but
she had passed away in 2013 excuse me
or actually know if you might have
passed away in 2012 well I know these
were recorded in 2012 and released in
2013 she had cancer and she actually
already knew that when she agreed to do
these so she was sick but she still
wanted to do these and she came in and
it takes absolutely nothing away from
her performance that she is not in good
health and I have a fondness for Romana
1 I think part of it probably has to do
with the first Fourth Doctor story that
I saw that I really loved was the pirate
planet which featured that version of
Romana I know a lot of people tend to
have a preference for the Lalla Ward
version of Vermont Romana to basically
and I don't dislike Romana 2 but there
is definitely a distinctively different
flavor there's a slightly more
antagonistic feel between Romano 1 and
the doctor whereas Romana 2 it's a bit
more of that playfulness they're more at
ease with each other to put it simply
whereas they did there's just a little
bit of a different quality to that
interaction and it was one that I was
happy to hear again because you know
wrote this version of Romana only got
that one season on the show the makita x
season so it was nice to get more the
other thing that's sort of the major
through-line on this these four stories
is the villain because here occurs
across all four of these now these these
aren't actually
back-to-back-to-back-to-back
if you were to listen to all of season 2
of Fourth Doctor adventures
these come in so first episode is
standalone
then it's sense of time war with a war
with the lon
then it's two standalone episodes and
then it's Dalek contract final phase so
the he's kind of spread out across the
season a little bit but it's a villain
by the name of Cuthbert who is voiced by
David Warner oh I love me some David
Warner if that name sounds vaguely
familiar
he's really well known for doing an
awful lot of villains some of his most
iconic he was the villain in Time
Bandits he was the main he was the main
villain besides the master control
program in Tron he was the sort of the
the the henchmen to Billy Zane's
character and Titanic that's David
Warner he's great and he's also really
good in this he also has a has a
sidekick basically a character named mr.
doric who it's also quite good and his
is with him through most of his stuff
they're kinds a little bit of a double
act but let's talk about these stories
in a little more specifics so first up
with the sands of life and war with the
lawn I'm just gonna I'm gonna treat it
as one thing because they really are a
two-parter they separate them out as if
they're two different stories they're
really not cuz that neither half is
complete without the other and it's not
even like oh well here's a story and
then we do a cliffhanger leading it no
story's not finished unless you listen
to both halves so what we have going on
here is that
Cuthbert and his company that he has
which is known as the conglomerate which
is this massively influential and
powerful organization that just has its
fingers in everything it's keys the
conglomerate is conducting some
experiments on space and what they're
tinkering with basically ends up
accidentally getting kind of sideswiped
by these creatures called the lawn which
are kind of the kind of space whales but
you know not all about water actually
all about sand and the space whales end
up on earth in the Sahara Desert
believing this to be their traditional
birthing grounds you know like salmon
salmon swimming upstream to give birth
to their young so that it's that kind of
situation that's all well and good
except that the energy is expelled by
these creatures when they give birth is
a massive hit of energy and if the
entire lawn population that has arrived
basically if they all move forward with
their birthing cycle it's actually gonna
wipe out all the other life on the
planet so that's the situation that
we're dealing with and that's the
situation that the doctor and Ramana
come in on and there's a lot of people
you know with a lot at stake here so the
other major character who's in this
particular one is the new president of
Earth who has been newly elected and she
was basically sort of swept in under a
protest vote because everybody knows the
conglomerate basically controls
everything and she was the most vocal
critic of the conglomerate so she was
swept into power but she's so she's
brand-new to the job but and she's very
quickly learning that it's one thing to
say I'll I won't just bend over and give
the conglomerate whatever they want and
then to deal with the reality of I
actually can't tell them no because we
kind of depend on them for like
everything like military medicine the
resources we use to just feed the
population is
is not entirely dependent but like a is
scale tipping lis dependent on this one
company so there's a reason that the
conglomerate has this degree of leverage
it's not the sort of political
corruption strong-arming you get in a
lot of stories which is usually cannot
going to be things like blackmail and or
you know extortion it's not it's just
this company and cut bird in particular
just flexing the muscle that he has
because the company is not it is that
that all reaching and so you know the
military has concerned about these
things they consider a threat Cuthbert
has a personal vendetta against them
because they basically screwed up his
experiment plus he thinks that maybe if
he got a hold of one and had somebody
dissect it they could learn something
from it so that's what's going on here
and this story doesn't really work and I
think the reason it works is not
necessarily inherent problems with the
story but I think it was a bad fit for
Big Finish it was a bad fit for an audio
medium because ultimately this
particular story is it's a monster of
the weak story it says it's a story that
where the primary focus is on the
creatures and when it's a completely
audio medium some of that gets lost
right off the bat you know given the
fact that well you know it's just these
you know these voices they do end up
giving the lawn kind of you know a voice
that it cuz again kind of speak in and
romana picks up the doctor doesn't in in
ramadas head but additionally it also
ends up being incredibly repetition
especially from an audio perspective I
think it might have played better with a
with a visual component but as an audio
and I actually I feel really bad for
Mary tam in this one because so much of
her dialogue is no you have to listen
wait you don't understand or variants of
that and then for the lawn honestly they
reminded me of a wire from the idiots
Lantern because I always talk about how
much I hate the fact that the wire
basically just keeps going
over and over and over again and the
lawn basically go the sun's of life we
must reach the sun's of life and
variance of that over and over and over
and over again and it's incredibly
repetitive and also like for the kinda
story it is it doesn't really support
being stretched out across to you know
halves for how little actually goes on
especially given that what they do to
stretch it out across this time frame is
to have the basically just have people
not communicate well so like there's a
whole there's multiple sections where
there's basically things going on where
ultimately it breaks down to you must
listen to me we won't listen to you you
must listen to me we won't listen to you
I'm gonna tell you anyway I've heard you
but I still don't believe you I'm like
what was the point of last five minutes
cuz it got us nowhere and we've already
established that these people aren't
gonna have their minds change so why did
we waste 10 minutes continuingly
establishing that and that happens with
multiple characters it happens with the
lawn it happens with cuthbert it happens
with the military characters it's just
it's frustratingly repetitive it's not
without redeeming qualities all as much
as I feel bad for Mary tam for the
dialogue she was stuck with she gives a
good performance and actually all the
performances are good and that is the
saving grace because when we take
moments away from the plot and have some
more character centric moments the
interactions between Cooper and Doric
and certainly the the president
character she's actually quite good I
like her a lot
and I like that that sort of whole thing
that's at play with her wanting to fight
against the conglomerate but she really
kinda can't and I actually found it to
be a surprisingly interesting and
nuanced dynamic I just wish it hadn't
just been a singular aspect in this
bigger story where the bigger story was
something that just wasn't great it was
it felt it felt generic and it felt like
something that they could have gotten
away with it in a visual medium with
good
visuals like the the clunkiness of the
storytelling would have been assisted by
a strong visual presentation and without
it you know it the the flaws become a
bit more apparent which again is
unfortunate the next half being the
Dalek contract and the final phase that
is better but because first of all I
mean let's be honest the Daleks are kind
of a great villain to do in audio medium
because they are so immediately distinct
you know to hear so it makes them a
really good drop and honestly the
Cybermen for kind of the same reason and
it's I think it's why more often than
not most of the Big Finish stories that
I've listened to not all but most seem
to involve somebody you know usually on
the villain end of things with an odd
voice you know there's sort of a phantom
reverb sound effect or there's an
electronic element to their voice or you
know there's a robot character in there
somewhere
and because those sorts of things work
well in an audio medium and so the
Daleks inherently I think work quite
well and so we have interesting
continuing tension between you know
Cuthbert and the doctor because now they
actually know each other a little bit
and which is actually kind of an
interesting point as well because a
comfort is it has a certain degree of
frustration because the doctor doesn't
know who he is and that's to cut Bert's
consternation cuz everybody knows who he
is but it's not quite in that petulant
level that like say Harry van Straten
if I'm saying it right this time I'd
always said it wrong well that's time I
talked about this episode a back in
Dalek from series one of revived Doctor
Who is it's it's not quite that level of
just childish insistence on his own
importance this guy actually genuinely
has a has a claim to importance but he's
there's also there's a lot of shades to
David warned his performance as Cuthbert
across all these that he's is oddly
relatable for lack of a better term and
I mean that in personality wise I'm not
necessarily in his goal there's
motivation
which we actually don't find out very
much about until the very last story out
of these four that I'm talking about but
he he has kind of this self-made man I
pulled myself up by my own bootstraps
feel to him and like his introductory
sentence in in the DA like contract is
he is mr. doar comes into his office and
he says the the kitchen better be better
be sending up that brown sauce I tell
them every time no chips without brown
sauce it's like you it's so weird that
guide this powerful dis rich with this
much influence is obsessing over not
having the right dip for its chips yeah
it's it's nice it's a nice touch and
it's it makes him much less of the I am
in control of everything generic sort of
thing that you might expect more from a
character in the positions that he's in
and it makes them more interesting to to
listen to and to hear things get play
out we also have new characters
introduced in this second story so I
didn't actually talk plot on this one
yet so the way this one works is
basically we're picking up on the thread
of the experiments that cuff bird is
running because that was sort of hinted
at in that first one sands of time in
war with the lawn and it's picked up on
here as we actually see a little bit
more about these experiments so these
aren't happening at or if these are
happening way off somewhere else and the
planets in the vicinity are being
basically wrangled by the Daleks who
have entered into a contract with
coffered yeah he is pompous enough to
think that he could negotiate a workable
contract with the Daleks and it's kind
of hilarious like even before things go
badly which I mean that's not a spoiler
they're gonna go badly that Cuthbert is
like he keeps throwing up the term oh we
have a contract like a shield as if it's
like he genuinely thinks that the Daleks
give a crap about the contract that he
got them to agree to
as if he's like what you gotta take the
Daleks to court is that is that your big
plan is that what you're gonna threaten
them with him oh do what you ask it's
just oh dude you have no idea what
you've gotten yourself into and that
that does sort of play out a little bit
across as things go but we've also got
sort of earth moment sorry not earth
planet level resistance run the people
who are battling against Cuthbert and
his space platform and obviously they
are now having to deal with the Daleks
as well and there's infighting going on
there because you have different groups
with different personal agendas things
that they want to accomplish sort of
separate from that and they are at AWS
and they don't like each other but they
kind of have to at least try to set
their differences aside if they're gonna
have even the slightest hope of you know
putting even a dent in what the Daleks
and Cuthbert are up to which they the
doctor ends up being the main driving
factor in in getting those those things
to start to pull together it's funny now
I think of it there's actually a
surprising number of stretches in both
and in all of these that I'm talking
about where the doctor and Romana are
separated so as much as it was nice to
have Mary came back she actually doesn't
interact directly with the doctor as
much as I would have thought not in
these ones anyways a little bit more on
some of the other ones from the season
which I'll talk about at a later date in
another video so what oh I forgot to
mention k9 is it is in these as well
John Leeson doing k9 and he's actually
quite well used especially given that he
you know they narrative Lee he's quite
well used because k9 depending on what
you haven't do is one of those things
that like honestly a bit like the sonic
screwdriver if you overuse him he kind
of breaks the story so you have to nerve
him just appropriately or isolate him in
a certain area so other things can go on
elsewhere and all that is handled pretty
well in terms of the final phase there
isn't really much I can talk to about
that one because the more interesting
elements of it get into sort of spoiler
ish things I
I did check even though it is a
closed-off story by the time you you get
through the final phase the cuthbert is
a character who who does reappear in
later audios I may have to track those
down though I'm not gonna do that right
away so overall for this chunk of them
and the the cuthbert related stories
from the season in particular they are
met to pretty good because it stands a
time war with the lawn while not a total
stinker is probably the weakest Big
Finish
story on you know spread across those
two those two installments that I heard
so far it's just not especially great
it's I I wouldn't say avoid it because
they the context does it does kind of be
necessary to listen to the dialect
contract in the final phase which is
better but it's it is it is on the weak
side but the the other ones are good but
even in the one that even in the ones
that are weaker David Warner is still
really good the doctor is still really
good
Romana is still really good k9 is fun
and well used mr. Doric is good in all
these and actually even the supporting
cast that are more isolated to the
separate stories is all good so it's all
good character work it's all good
performances it's just a question of
whether the story that they're in is
working anding Dalek contract and the
final phase basically yeah in sands of
life and war with the lawn basically not
really so I think I'll wrap it up there
then consider it a soft recommendation I
think it depends on your own personal
fondness for the Fourth Doctor and or
role model one if you have the same
fondness for these characters that I do
it's probably worth listening to these
even getting through some of the weaker
stuff so I think I will wrap that up
there any of these that I've talked
about or the Fourth Doctor audio
adventures in general have you heard of
them what ones do you like what are your
thoughts on these particular ones or
whatever else you want to tell
my way he dropped something down the
comments let's talk about a whole bunch
of stuff you can do because there's
buttons and there's links including one
to my patreon where you may have noticed
that I mentioned it you get to vote on
what Big Finish stories I do and things
along those lines so give that a look if
you feel like it if you don't don't
worry there's other links you can check
out if you don't even want to look at
them don't sweat that either because at
the end of the day you're the council I
just run the meetings and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]